actually I'm kind of wondering if I
close my eyes and type on the phone how
accurate it can be right now Ren's
working I'm gonna send my text message
Masum all the projects going we just get
one last look at those keyboard here I
could also really Tyson the offensive I
have no idea what's going to happen here
we go ready and so today we have
something super super special in this
box this has been sitting in the studio
for the last 48 hours burning a hole in
the back of my mind he's just waiting to
open this I would kind of want to say
this kind of spiraled out of control a
little bit my computer in my workstation
in the studio kind of got turned into a
shelf with my absence my personal desk
and computer turn over to Christian the
desk itself just became a junk pile
leaving me in a position where I didn't
really have a desk or a workstation to
use I ended up taking the sound
workstation the one that's in the back
here typically reserved for sound
editing and mixing etc however a lot of
other people didn't like how I was
always using this communal workstation
and I started thinking I think it's
about time we call it Puget and see if
we can figure out what my next work
stations gonna look like after years
using a computer and typing we never
actually really learned how to type
without looking at the keyboard I mean
I'm pretty good I know where stuff is
not just instinctually but if I close my
eyes and type on the phone how accurate
it can be that's our export apparently
like people said I've when I was really
solid autocorrect I know corrects things
sometimes you don't want to but for the
most part it's pretty good right now
Ren's working I'm inside I'm a text
message I could also really type
something offensive I've no idea what's
going to happen here we go ready and
house Ren did you get a text Anika
wait what is a glitch hold on I'm gonna
text you something dude I'm just trying
to send a coherent text message to my
friend to Jake's looking at me like I'm
crazy
I'm gonna send Jake a message to clear
things up a Jake I am trying to type
with out looking at my hey Jake
um trying to those sit here looking G my
phone let me respond back to Niko quick
okay
but you got no eyes okay that sounds
good I'll talk to you didn't let me get
let me get this straight
I'm supposed to write a text message to
you with my eyes closed and it's already
that's what autocorrect Hanako comma I
think the drone video is doing great
exclamation point so you know voice the
text drone video is going to be really
cool in the future when we're able to
finally finish it and release it to the
world for everyone to enjoy
exclamation point let's send the drone
video is going to be really cool in I'm
doesn't win we are able to turn off
sleep finish and LA I have all think I
would though be honest on Facebook joy
be there smiley face
some of those weird words that you guys
sometimes type go into your like Auto
memory thing where that's like those
weird words you don't want people know
that you type often show up you go this
is funny and all that I think we need to
raise the stakes how do you wanna raise
the stakes
I'm gonna point this nerf gun at
shonduras his head and it's up to you to
warn him to turn around I play a
specific role in the studio when it
comes to the things I am best at 3d work
I do a lot of After Effects works but
once again most computers can have that
anyone can do the effects the difference
is that I also do a lot of the audio
work in this video become a big music
and audio background so I decided on top
of making a good generalist visual
effects computer workstation what can we
do to this machine that makes it a
little more audio orient 4050 audio
layers what's the best workstation I can
use to get like low latency really fast
load times and have the best audio
working experience we've been talking
with Eric Brown over at Puget systems
and he's been a huge help because that
the computers and the workstations they
put together are some of the most
professionally created machines and
workstations in the world these guys
have created workstations for NASA
related activities among other things so
take a look
hey Shawn
nick is standing behind you and if you
don't turn Oh No I spelled that wrong
around now you get shot I should just
text them turn around John all right
send
[Music]
[Laughter]
I can't even show the camera this cuz
it's inappropriate so so I told Nico
behind you there's not a single word of
warning except for flu he wrote the word
flu twice
can you read that message for us with
accepting case um Blanc gain nick is
Sebastian gun behind God if flu song
dubs subs bid flu bad z FK f how did I
not know and you're responsible for your
friend's birthday I know I guess if our
lives are on the line I'll at least they
make sure have my eyes open so context
things this is hard you know sometimes
it's accurate like Jake almost got it
through but it's harder than I think
autocorrect is maybe now it's all
powerful eyes I think it's also I think
I just screwed that up emoji eyes closed
Sean's like really blind
this is what actual people I haven't
tried to use like exclamation marks and
stuff hitting send
thanks Inc go do you get so rig that
awesome merch beat us the link in the
bio BB does that's where you got that
awesome merchant if the link was in the
bio that's pretty close I text a lot oh
I just got a text message if you like
our secure she goes ol consider sink
diving subscribing
if you like our videos consider
subscribing consider sink diving I
printed out the parts list what started
out as a really good audio workstation
and turned it out to be the best
computer in the studio by like triple so
I better get some damn good use out of
this thing the instructions are just
constantly flipping each box upside down
it's like toothpaste coming out wow this
is one spicy case gosh each time I pull
this list I like I get lightheaded this
is what a $9,000 PC looks like when I
use it's not a competition right okay I
open the wrong what makes a good audio
workstation and also a good the effects
generalist workstation how do we combine
these together well let's load it up
with a beefy processor LBP GPU that
covers the visual effects in right there
but for audio low latency and drawing
lots of files things like that we
decided to actually wire together a cool
little SSD cache effectively inside up
here we we have our operating system we
have our storage but we're also using
another SSD here that is exclusively
going to be for the cache
basically the cache is where
applications put their temporary files
each time you preview a file or
something like that it's saving the
previews and all the the cache the
memory to this one specific ultra-fast
drive and just overall just makes using
any application that has to sling big
files around incredibly speedy hen core
processor with a gigabyte X 299
motherboard Intel I 970 900 x10 core
processor I 9 we have 128 gigs of ram
ddr4 soliton atti GPU 2 terabyte SSD for
the operating system take a deep breath
these are huge
we are using a one terabyte m2 SSD drive
as the core OS drive that holds the
operating system we also have another 2
terabytes SSD which will be our general
storage and applications drive and then
we have one more 2 terabyte SSD drive
which is just going to be for caching
file it's got a cool power supply
thousand watts that's basically it this
is the classiest thing of all
each time they ship you a machine they
also include a binder and inside that
binder not only is it starts with a
thank-you letter but they lists all your
software serial keys for Windows 10
don't look at that they have the MAC
address all the technical information
they have photos of the exact system
they sent you for quality control
purposes they also have thermal imaging
of the computer idling and at a full
load you can see that their full list of
specs motherboard connections
troubleshooting guide for this machine
specifically activation help a build
checklist which lists everything that
was done to the machine and at exactly
what time and who did it done by Houston
on 9 22 17 at 242 this isn't some like
run of the nail this isn't like
something out of the factory that's like
kind of booted once or twice and sent
off this thing here is a no alien where
I know so this is your new office though
this is where you're gonna be set up I
mean sure I mean honestly I don't like
this fun anyway it's in the corner like
I can't see out there
we're gonna raise the stakes here Nikko